this is what has been being undermined
this is the liberal approach and it's
what Jonathan Roush calls liberal
science that process where everybody can
raise any idea they want anybody else
can challenge that idea there's the
belief that we can all get at ideas and
examine them on their own merits and
that the individual has agency to reject
some ideas and uphold others so this to
the post-modernists is very very naive
it's either an extreme naivety and an
inability to see the invisible Powers uh
Power structures or it's a selfish
attempt to protect one's own privilege
so you see for some extent there is of
course truth in this because if we look
at how our understanding of
homosexuality Has Changed For example
dominant discourses for a long time said
it was a heinous sin then it said it was
a shameful disorder now the dominant
discourse around homosexuality is some
people are gay get over it so this has
changed but whereas the Liberals would
say this has changed because we were
able to look at it talk about it discuss
it apply science to it and um you know
really sort of compare Arguments for
what homosexuality is does it have any
moral valence at all and that was how we
overcame um prejudice against
homosexuality but the the discourse
theorists the the descendants of the
post-modernist would say this is naive
and what all that has happened is that
the ways of talking about things have
changed we are still living in a very
um heterocentrist and uh CIS Centrist
society and that those power structures
are still there and they still need to
be dismantled and they think that we're
going to do that by changing the way
that we talk about things
yes precisely if if language creates
social reality changing language can
create a better one and if you think
that like if one thinks that uh we're in
this sort of invisible web there's this
power web and we're all of us at
positioned according to our
characteristics
uh we maybe even don't see these things
until somebody has taught us the
techniques of critical whatever Theory
how can it like it sounds like we're
trying to pull ourselves up by our
bootstraps if you believe that you can
change the way that you talk and that
will change reality like it is
incredibly pessimistic and I don't know
how they think if you think like that
how they think that you can even change
your language well some theorists have
argued that that it's almost impossible
Christy Dotson
um for example when she does her um
conceptual conceptualizing epistemic
oppression she says that third level
that one where you have to try to to
even speak in the language that you have
trying to see that there is a problem
when you only have the language the the
epistemic resources that you have is
almost impossible so there is a lot of
um of pessimism there but there's also a
certain Simplicity to it and there's a
certain appeal to it because people feel
as though we're only at the beginning we
can't they don't know not even at the
most advanced theorists
um in the world know or how exactly how
this power system works but what we're
doing is we're picking at it we're
digging at it we're trying to see it
we're uncovering more bits of it because
it's unfalsifiable somebody can identify
racism within any interaction and as
long as it's um according to the theory
it will be deemed authoritative it will
be correct so there's there's a lot of
um a lot of room for people to play with
these ideas for them to interpret things
and and to them feel like you're really
uncovering new ground and setting the
the scene for improving things right so
they feel like they're making progress
because when there's no force of
viability everything is sort of
progressed every bit of thing that you
say
yeah I mean it's beginning to be able to
see it that that's the thing the Angela
often says we need to make it visible
and then we can get at it I mean I think
the second bit of that doesn't
necessarily follow from the first but
since I don't agree with the first
either I think that's going to be
relevant
um I thought it was very interesting the
way you talked I think it was it was um
maybe an article just very recently you
said this thing about what cancer
culture really is and there was a great
explanation that the point of cancer
culture is that if people are saying
wrong things and those wrong things are
creating wrongness then silence them is
an extremely moral thing to do and
silencing them by any means really
um and you don't have to debate them
debating them will be bad have I got
that about right yes exactly I think
this makes intuitive sense to humans I
mean this is why there have been such
strong
um laws against heresy and blasphemy
because the idea is you can corrupt
Society you can taint and damn others
so you know when we had awful things
like the Inquisition this was a moral
Endeavor because the attempt was to stop
this corruption from spreading and
damning a lot of people to hell
and so yes they wanted to put very very
strong disincentives in place for people
to question
um the Orthodoxy of religion now this is
a different situation because we're in a
different time but the same um
the same sorry my husband not got his
keys can you let Daddy in please
shall I ask you the question again I
think you were going pretty well so I
don't want to maybe not from the
Inquisition that was good
so uh yeah so we um
yeah even with things like the
Inquisition which were with such a sort
of terrorizing
um thing there was a moral imperative uh
underneath that the idea was that if
people
um speak heresy if they they challenge
the
um the Orthodoxy the the truth of God
this this can um this this will corrupt
and um and taint the rest of society and
cause and cause people to be damned to
hell so there's this incentive to really
make
um to ensure that people are thinking
and speaking in the right way for the
good of everybody and that's what you
get right now I mean the the strongest
Mantra I think that people are wanted
are expected to repeat at the moment is
trans women are women
and so what no matter what you actually
believe about trans identity I'm
um fully in support of trans trans right
some like people identifying as they
wish to with you know there's obviously
conversations that need to be happened
about spaces and sports but
no matter what you think about this we
it's difficult to notice that the
emphasis is is very much on language
are you saying things which suggest that
trans women aren't women the way to
respond to that is not with an argument
so we don't have people arguing back and
forwards as much as we have them and
throwing mantras at each other as if
they're trying to
um to to out out speak each other on the
level of these discourses if I say trans
women are women often enough if enough
people say it that will make the social
reality be what is needed for the
acceptance of trans people
yeah it's interesting because I had I
must say I had sort of thought that
anyone who hung on to a mantra that much
couldn't possibly really believe it you
know that if you're if you feel secure
in your own ideas I'd always thought but
then there's just shows that I'm from a
previous generation I was taught if you
were secure in your ideas you wouldn't
mind debating them you'd feel confident
that you could answer any criticism that
people put forward but I think what you
showed you know and you you gave me a
different way to conceive of this
was it the very saying of these things
was a harm
and I hadn't understood that before that
you know I was creating an evil
according to these people by saying
things even possibly if I was saying
them on my own in a room I'm not even
meant to think them I'm not even meant
to say them in my head I guess yeah I
mean this is why we get the argument
that um gender critical feminists are
involved in the murder of trans women
even though you know trans women do seem
to be particularly vulnerable to
violence but this isn't um has never
been by a gender critical feminist but
there's this idea that they're speaking
into a narrative that devalidates
invalidates delegitimizes
um trans people it creates a hostile
environment and one in which it is
acceptable for them to be abused by
people who have completely different
ideas and aren't feminists at all so
it's um yeah it seems it seems quite
remarkable I mean it's you know
I mean I lived in Brazil for several
years and I mean that is one of the
places where trans women are murdered I
mean you know it's actually one of the
hot spots of it in Rio de Janeiro
because there's a lot of street workers
there you know yeah they're not
listening to what gender-critical
feminists are saying I mean these men
it's nothing to do with it's nothing to
do with that it's
you know some mixture of violence
homophobia to be honest self-hatred etc
etc you know and just being violent is
there any really so convinced if they
think it through or is the point that
they're stopping themselves from
thinking it through by saying the Mantra
like is it a thought-stopping cliche
I I think it's I have a tendency to
think that it is actually quite normal
quite intuitive to humans to think that
our words have more power
than they do I think um that the idea
that if we can just get everybody saying
the right thing everything will be okay
actually makes a lot of sense to us
we're a storytelling species so I think
what's more counter-intuitive to us is
the idea that there can be worth in
getting people together who have two
different uh views on a thing and
getting them to argue their own side
using evidence and a reasoned argument
this this doesn't seem to make a lot of
sense to a lot of the activists right
now
and it hasn't made a lot of sense
historically I think people like um you
and I and our Our Generation and people
who have been involved in having these
kind of conversations we can it seems
that this is the obvious way you know we
talk about things we we exchange ideas
this is how we progress but it doesn't
seem to be that intuitive to a lot of
people yeah so maybe it was a brief
period but it was a brief and very
glorious period I think it's something
we have to yeah we have to hang on to it
we have to cons constantly reinforce it
otherwise it we are likely to lose it
and it will be the most powerful
narrative wins
so what let's see and I want to ask you
what you think this means for two
particular large areas very important
areas of society that I think are really
under attack at the moment one is
Academia and the other one is journalism
so Academia seems to have pretty much
Fallen to these ideas at least large
chunks of it
I I think it's certainly
um very much overpowered by it of course
you get um I I don't think the majority
of academics hold these views and
they're you don't find them in it in
every field they really sort of
concentrated in a cluster in the
humanities and also on campus culture
but anybody who goes against them
is likely to find themselves in trouble
so this is what I was I found when I'm
studying um late medieval women's
religious writing now I can look I can
do work that I can be proud of as long
as I'm not looking at what sex is what
gender is how it works in any way that's
going to go against the dominant
narrative
you know so somebody wanted to be a
historian and they wanted to look at
agriculture or something they should go
through their whole lives without coming
uh Cropper with this but if you're a
scientist and you want to look at say
how sex differences exist between men
and women then you're going to find
yourself in trouble
isn't it because I think that's a bit of
it that people don't see if they're
outside what we might call a knowledge
producing industry so I'll count
journalism as that even even if it's not
very fair but it's it's the it's the
self-censorship it's before you even get
to the area that's touchy so it's not
it's not about the people who recite
it's about the people who never said
anything more than anything else
yes I hear it from a lot of academics I
hear from a lot of people generally who
write to me and say I you know I think
I'm the only person in my organization
who is concerned about this and then
quite often now I happen to know that
they're not and I can put them in touch
with somebody else and I I think there's
a lot more people who are
um concerned about it or who at least
don't agree with it I think with a lot
of liberals on the left who still
actually have those kind of beliefs that
I'd like them to have about the value of
different ideas and and the exchange of
debate and consistent principles they
tend to
understand the social justice approaches
are more friendly and liberal thing than
it is and feel that they should be
supportive of it and the scholars
producing it because the problem on the
right is um is a more severe one if you
if you are a leftist yes we're going to
worry about the rise of right-wing
populists and they then get rather
annoyed with people on the left who are
saying yes but this is a problem that's
on the left it is a problem we do need
to address it and more than that they're
connected aren't they
yeah so you tell me about how you think
they're connected then
I I don't think I think there are two
ways if you if you are a leftist and you
want left-wing parties to win and be
able to
um Institute left-wing policies there
are two things you have to do you have
to show the problem with the party on
the right and you have to make your own
party a strong one and one that people
can respect and I don't think that's
happening on the left at the moment I
think that there's this division between
the identitarians the radicals and the
Liberals
on the left and at the moment the
identity politics left is the one that
is most visible it's the one that
corporations and politicians feel that
they have to appease and I think it's
driving people right now I can't know
how many people went right because of
this and um so it's not very helpful to
guess but I do think that if we could
have a more consistently liberal left
then we could see then we'd have been a
better chance of getting people to vote
left again
so the profession that worries me most I
have to say because it's the one I'm in
is journalism and I think you see a lot
of the same tendencies in particular the
self-censorship
uh not surprisingly I suppose I mean a
lot of money has gone out of Journalism
a lot of people have gone out of
Journalism it's become a low paid um
very temporary and Casual sort of work
that young people come into and they
have no time no specialism no support
from older journalists and of course
they're all graduates now and most of
them have come in from the sorts of
courses where they learned this sort of
stuff so I'm absolutely astounded at how
fast this has happened that journalism
has been hollowed out and I also see
this as part of the political problem
because
Ordinary People slowly get the sense
that they're not actually reading what's
going on they're reading a sort of a
self-censored version of it in what are
meant to be the papers of record so you
have a you have your own magazine you
edit a sort of a new magazine is this
part of the motivation for you that you
you see
um no other place to put the sorts of
things that you want to say yeah and
that was why Ariel was um was created in
the first place by malham Mali he wanted
something that wasn't
um left-wing or right-wing or but
something that would have views from
both sides but would argue them
straightforwardly with
um evidence and reason
and so that that is what we try to do we
have quite a lot of leftists who write
for us but a few of them are the social
justice leftists they tend to be
socialists or um social Democrats and we
have quite a lot of conservatives as
well and and Christians and they will
write from from their belief systems and
this I think works well we don't require
people to be apolitical but we do
require them to both state what their
what political position they're coming
from is and try to look charitably and
concede as much as they can to the one
they're criticizing yeah yeah so that's
so okay I'm going to take a bit of a
leap a sort of a side step here and say
um how fascinating I find it endlessly
fascinating the way that uh race in one
bucket and then what we might say sex
gender and sexuality in another bucket
how incredibly differently theorized
these two things are so race which
actually is this fluid learns sort of
category uh you know I mean the race
line was drawn differently in different
countries at different times Etc is
regarded as the most rigid possible
thing and sex gender sexuality when you
know sex is incredibly rigid sexuality
for feels for most people quite binary
not everybody but most gender less so
but I mean compared with race you know
how did that happen how did he end up
sort of almost the wrong way around
there
okay so I I think that we've come from
different
um different places so queer Theory
which is where a lot of the sort of
gender Theory and trans activism comes
from that's the most purely post-modern
so it believes that there is a problem
with having with knowledge and that it's
been constructed in the service of power
so to get at that we have to look at the
categories through which we think and to
try to to blur those boundaries
dismantle those categories and stop um
putting people into them they believe
that
um if we get rid of all all categories
that aren't you know feminine women
attracted to men or masculine men
attracted to women then the world will
become a more welcoming place to the
people who don't
um naturally fit into the pathogories so
we've got that whole um fluid thing
going on there and in fact queer has
become a a verb and to queer something
is to blur the boundaries and to mix up
the categories so that that's one
it relies quite a lot on um deridan fuco
so when we're going into critical race
Theory this comes from a different
lineage that has quite a lot of
of input from the radical new left
and then it has the postmodern influence
on top so Kimberly Crenshaw when she
described intersectionality she
described it as contemporary politics by
which she meant the radical activism
um linked to postmodern Theory by which
she meant the idea of everything being
culturally constructed but she wanted
um some acceptance of objective truth to
be there she criticized the
postmodernists saying that you know we
can't just dismantle everything we have
to accept that some things are
objectively true or we can't achieve
anything so those systems of power and
privilege had to be seen as true and I
think because this comes from America
and because there really has been that
rigid line in America you know there has
been that one drop rule if you are black
at all then you are black and so this
the whole sort of um identity politics
to push back at this has taken this as
well as as a solid category they don't
think that race is a biological category
they do think it's a social construct
but they think it's been constructed
very simply into white supremacy and
black
um subordination